within a couple of years you now have
this sort of fundamental right to
transgenderism
and all of these kind of radical sexual
ideologies
the acceleration was really really quick
we went from barack obama
saying that it would be unconstitutional
to give out executive amnesty
just to the dreamers right and the
dreamers actually they're now as old as
44 years old but at least the image of
the dreamers is that they're supposed to
be like six years old and they're really
cute and
you know their parents brought them over
and it's not their fault and we got to
give them
amnesty we went from barack obama saying
that would be unconstitutional to
it's so in effect
that even donald trump can't overturn it
he tried courts shut it down
now we're at the place where joe biden
says we're going to give amnesty to 11
million people
path to citizenship future democratic
voters and that
and that is just a fact by the way i'm
not i'm hoping
that somehow these voters will become
conservative republicans i hope reagan
is right when he says that
a lot of these voters are republicans
they just don't know it yet but the
public opinion polls don't really bear
it out it would seem that
that recent immigrants from latin
america
identify with the democratic party
overwhelmingly you're talking about
80 percent plus and which is of course
the reason why democrats are so keen
on on pushing for amnesty that's a
radical policy
right but we don't we don't feel like
it's radical because we're like the
we're like the frog in the hot water we
as things continue to heat up and heat
up
and get more radical and more radical
we're just not paying attention to it
and there is the full force of the media
higher education lower education for
that matter big tech
especially now big tech we'll get to
that in a second the bureaucracy
everybody is pushing for it and so
ordinary americans who maybe don't have
institutional power
and certainly have zero institutional
power now that trump is leaving they're
gonna look up and say wait a second what
what is happening you're gonna legalize
11 million people
and then you're going to upend the
voting system or you're going to keep
the upended voting system that we had
in 2020 this doesn't this doesn't look
good guys and there's not going to be
very much to do about it
because the entire weight of the
establishment is
behind it if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
you